he's always going to be a liar he's
always been a liar he's always been a
bigot he's always going to be a bigot
so why do we keep saying oh my god i
can't believe that he's a bigot of
course he is
oh my god i can't believe he's a liar of
course he's a liar that's who he is
core leopard doesn't change his stripes
of course leopards don't change their
stripes
they don't have stripes those are tigers
dumbass
next on cnn do zebras change their spots
[Applause]
[Music]
oh we're ruining his brain i tell you
killing him in the ratings he's falling
apart all right
i spend a fair portion of time talking
about crime but that's because as a
small government fan
but a huge tv star
that's not funny that's not a laugh line
cat
it's really the only thing i want
addressed by our politicians
that and the height requirement for
theme park rides
i mean are the teacups really that
dangerous and maybe i did watch too many
cop shows as a kid in fact while other
kids played doctor
i played stop and frisk but if we can
create
safe societies everyone benefits equally
you're more free to pursue your dreams
be it an education or your career
or my favorite hobby which is sorting
through the air in a porta potty
oh you should have seen what it looked
like inside
but all of this is hard to do in a
society in which thugs are allowed to
roam free like locally raised free-range
chicken when crime goes up your
opportunity for a reasonable existence
on this planet
drops faster than cat's bank account on
st patrick's day
la county sheriff alex villanova said
his department will be expanding
concealed weapons permits
i bet you want to know why because we
have less cops on the street more crooks
less consequences you know what could go
wrong with that combination right
we've uh we've increased our capacity to
process ccw permits
we've made the good cause standard
achievable and
we're recognizing that the threat to the
residents is increasing so we're
responding accordingly
so less cops more crooks less
consequences
that results in more guns for residents
so thank you democrats
citizens now get to fight crime then of
course they run the risk of being
arrested for defending themselves
but the sheriff has little choice the
crime stats for la are as staggering as
the city's
drug-addicted transients homicides are
up 95
95 grand theft auto 40 rape is up 7.8
percent
aggravated assault 12.9 arson's up 22
where is robocop when you need him the
sheriff calls the rise in crime an
existential threat
and he's right but where have you heard
that phrase before it's usually
democrats and their compliant media
attaching it to stuff they read about on
a campus flyer
climate change is an existential risk
old white men are an existential threat
trump was the existential risk of all
time
but it's hard to argue what is
existential because by definition it's
imprecise
or it's because you've been shot it's
true right now being murdered by a
psychopath
is your existential risk however that's
the only thing that isn't an
existential risk according to the media
and don't look to joe biden or as he
calls himself
president harris to him the real
violence comes from a well-oiled
organized white supremacy movement
which i guess is what they call
republicans these days
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal
threat to the homeland today not isis
not al-qaeda white supremacists
you'd have to go to a presentation on
weapons of mass destruction to find a
phonier threat
remember the looting in riots from last
summer i don't recall seeing white power
groups
inciting that unless he counts cnn
and the dramatic rise in crime it's all
in cities it's not in the back woods
maybe the white racists are people like
portland's mayor who let it happen who
knows
my prediction as the crime gets worse so
will these deflections
they'll blame systemic racism faster
than you could say please stop punching
me in the head
meanwhile as crime continues to explode
the news
tries to convince you that it's your
duty to eat cicadas
to help the environment which reminds me
what's on cnn right now
how many cicadas have you eaten today
this is 500 for me why do you hate the
plants i'm doing my bus to me as many as
i can
i do i don't know where my kids are
you're a queer
what they're eating besides crow at cnn
so what you're seeing in la is the
natural response to politicians
abdicating their responsibility and
protecting
citizens in other words it's called
self-preservation
i envy la they have a sheriff who cares
about a city
in new york we have a mayor who thinks
his sit-up routine takes priority over
brutalized asians
and all of us are unarmed it takes
filling out 40 forms to get a caulking
gun
and the gov and the mayor like it that
way we're living in a video game where
unstable maniacs get to attack citizens
freely
and losing the game could mean losing
your life there is no escape button
and you never get to start over here's a
partial and i stress
partial list of our local terrors
courtesy of the new york post
last friday a homeless man allegedly
punched another asian woman down a
flight of stairs at a subway station
the suspect had 77 prior arrests
that's almost double cats in january a
deranged man shoved
a commuter into a moving train just two
weeks in february saw more than a dozen
attacks including a number of subway
slashings
a woman shoved onto the tracks and a bus
operator struck with the 2x4
which is impressive since under biden
the cost of lumber
is through the roof in early may a
harlem man was shoved to the tracks in
an unprovoked attack
on may 23rd four people including a cop
were attacked in two separate incidents
where one attacker wielded a hammer in
the subway
the list literally goes on and on and
our leaders offer nothing but platitudes
and when their cowardice shows they
point fingers at you the racist
so what happens when your national
leaders refuse to acknowledge the mayhem
around you
their silence becomes the existential
threat and this one is real
these rock more panels than the plywood
section at home depot
hosted kennedy unbox business network
[Music]
his chuckle makes my knees buckle
washington times opinion editor boston's
contributor charlie
he's america's favorite black gay
veteran republican
or at least in the top 200. host of the
podcast
rob smith is problematic rob smith
and for community service she reads
folks to the deaf
fox news contributor cast him
charlie i go to you first because
apparently you were kicked in the head
by a horse
yeah i was were you really kicked in the
head uh when i wasn't kicked out
i headbutted in the head what how were
you what situation brian i was getting
on the horse
and the horse was misbehaving and and
the horse threw his head back as i
and as you get older and fatter it gets
you it requires more momentum to get
over you know to swing your fat tail
over the the back of the horse and
we butted heads from behind you know i'm
not going to explore the
weird kinkiness that you're into i don't
buy that you were riding a horse because
this happened
at a club downtown so anyway we'll skip
that those are all euphemisms yes they
are but um
is what's more of a lethal threat to the
homeland you
your horse or white supremacy uh
definitely the horse yes
without a doubt uh but i mean i mean
this whole thing it's kind of funny i
mean this is what the whole
second amendment is about in the first
place you know the whole point of
and you know i get it before there was
9-1-1 there was the second amendment
and people could protect themselves
protect their families protect their
neighbors
we were the police and in a lot of parts
of this country we're still
the police right and uh so so hats off
to l.a county i think they're
you know that's going in the right
direction yeah i don't know how it works
but i mean it's amazing that he could
just decide to do that and we can't do
that here
rob we were in the green room yes and
you told me something that was very
disheartening to me because
uh what did you tell it about
minneapolis oh yeah about minneapolis so
um
with the help of a lot of people that
watch this network and a lot of my
followers
i raised about 130 000 um i crowdfunded
it last year to go give back to
minneapolis after it got
you know burned down by the blm horde
and then they just ruined everything all
over again so i'm just like
um that's not gonna happen again but
i'll tell you when i watch the stuff
with uh joe biden he's talking about you
know white guys being the biggest threat
when i walked in the green room and saw
you and charlie i was just terrified
you should be i i had to call security
yeah yeah you know
what killed me about that that that that
sound on tape of joe biden kennedy
is that he says that the white
supremacist is the is the biggest threat
but he doesn't name
a group but then he goes it says it's
bigger than isis and al qaeda
so he knows the names of these terror
groups
but he can't say and that but this group
is worse well what's the group is it
republicans
or is it you know i don't know what you
can but you can make a vague declaration
like that and as long as you keep it
vague you never have to walk it back
yeah you never have to make a correction
as long as you don't give proof right
and the horrible thing is the press
especially the press except for peter
ducey who covers
the white house they don't demand proof
and they're doing an incredible
disservice
because that means there could be other
groups out there who really do want to
harm cities uh tomorrow on my podcast
i'm going to talk to andy noe who is the
uh the journalist who
i know was one of the few people who
covers antifa he was beat up
again about six days ago and they wanted
to kill him they want to kill him
because
you know his book is called unmasked
because he is unmasking
the organization it's not just an idea
it's not just a few people and by the
way do you remember over the summer
we were watching riots in places like
minneapolis in portland and here in new
york
they were saying well these are trump
supporters these are trump supporters
and they're just infiltrating and
they're causing trouble
well then the election passed joe biden
won and portland is still burning to the
ground
and it still is a feces-covered hell
hole
of homeless camps filled with antifa
people who want to do nothing but
dismantle the government
and harm the city so screw those people
and oddly enough
who was at the january sixth event was a
blm supporter who was right there do you
remember that guy who then ended up on
cnn
do you guys remember yeah absolutely you
got a youtube video right yeah you did
they paid what 70 grand for that thing
but then i think they took the money
from
but that i mean it's pure projection all
right cat let's talk about new york city
so they released all these people from
from new york um
you're a libertarian do you now are you
now convinced that we need prisons
[Laughter]
first of all i'd like to say just with
regards to the monologue and a little
cnn bit
yeah i had to eat a lot of chocolate
covered snap peas this morning
so i don't they weren't good yes uh i
don't ever want you to say i don't do
anything for you
that was the best work that brianna
keller has ever done on cnn was eating
i probably would have rather eaten a
cicada well the thing is
i just as a libertarian i think what la
is doing is great i would love to be
able to protect myself
and have be able to conceal carry
because it is bad out there yesterday
we were out you know husband and i were
walking carl who's my dog
it's not some kind of weird kink thing
um
and there was we were on the sidewalk
and there was these people sprawled out
like tweaking out going crazy so we're
like okay we'll move to the other side
of the street
reach the other side and as we look to
the other side some other guy turns the
corner
going insane screaming about killing yes
and we're just there with our french
bulldog
i mean it's completely unfair that
people who are law abiding can't you
know and if i want to protect myself
i could go to prison yes you could you
could not fail you kill me to apologize
[Laughter]
you know he wasn't he told me he was
embarrassed about scaring me
can i just add something very quickly
exactly so the reason alex villanueva
the la county sheriff is saying
you know make sure you arm yourself is
because the response time is so
great and there's so many cops whether
it's lapd
or in the the sheriff's department yes
who have resigned as they have in
portland and new york and everywhere
else
and this isn't the first city in
california the city manager in san
bernardino
in 2012 said well we're out of money
folks so you may as well
just uh arm yourself and lock the door
because 9-1-1 is not coming
i just got to say as somebody who fled
new york and moved down to the great
state of florida you guys are not
help making me miss uh new york at all
well that you know to your point then we
got to go
uh the people at home who don't live in
new york or in l.a must just like
are looking at us going you guys would
you just shut up
and get the hell out of these cities but
i but if we do then we won't have all
this great content
like what are we going to do am i going
to do the a block about how great it is
to live in florida
nobody's going to watch that but i if
this this violent porn
geez and i don't even like i think i'm
going crazy i'm like ahab
and this is the whale no and they're all
sitting there watching this and you know
what they're thinking
they're thinking you know what it really
is true it might be a cliche but it's
true
an armed society is a very polite state
it certainly is and we also need to
enforce
and start using kendra's law more and
forcing crazy people off the street in
to get
uh their treatment although i'm sure
cats against that anyway hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else